[Applaudissements]
on sait imiter les savants on sait
imiter
oui je sens bien que la flamme cette
séquence
écoutez c'est très simple vous avez un
groupe de symétrie un groupe de symétrie
ce calcul selon mais non on n'est pas
d'accord avec mon collègue on n'est
jamais d'accord parce que vous savez les
publications 5 en valeur un conte
dissymétrie par exemple de type
florencia elles sont 3 1 340 / gauck
ancien consciente et pendant des mois
par ses sur trois mais ça c'est vous ça
normal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dites moi si je me trompe on l'est sur
un concept de coupe en glace à
l'italienne
[Rires]
abbas a remercié le concept de coûts big
bang
j'adore mais à dieu bénisse les chômeurs
au mas vous sortez tous les deux un peu
plus de écoute bien ça dure comme
nervosité tombe dans les mains
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mon corps la bande ils ont fini